what's one song because we've been
talking about how music is so healing
and gets us through
um all these moments and especially the
all the several moments we're having
right now
um what's karen what's like a song that
you've kind of been listening to you
think that's been really
helping oh gosh um i've been going back
to like
some al green like let's stay together
you know you gotta we need some cheering
up
and i think for everybody um it can just
be
whatever you need that anthem to be
that's the great thing about music it's
like
you know if you're in the mood to rock
out or whatever i've also been
crazy obsessed with dave girl playing
drums with this little girl from
from england who is an incredible
drummer and you have to look her up and
they've been going back and forth
and she's been learning drum solos and
and he's been challenging her every
like everybody wrote a song and he wrote
a song so
i think her name is candy i saw this i
actually saw this online and i was like
he is the coolest guy
ever it's amazing yes well jimmy what
about you what what about your your song
uh probably the one i've listened to the
most during this time because it's just
upbeat and everybody's living for that
happy thing is sunday sunday's best i
love that song
that's kind of oh that's a field goal oh
i love that uplifting okay phillip go
for it
i like uh i've been pulling out some old
vinyls and listened to them and i found
my tears for fears and played shout
out let it all out yeah and that guy is
really fun
yeah we've all needed some kimberly how
about you you know what i
love the new thomas rhett collaboration
with all his friends doing be a lot
i think that song is it's like it's like
a message from heaven right now with
um reba yeah and all kinds
yeah that's that's a good one so karen
when when you first started out
um you lost your label you lost the deal
so what did
you do to make ends meet oh gosh we all
had
um different jobs i ended up working on
a desk
for um an agent in town a booking agent
so
touring and i was booking other young
like rock bands
and christian bands and uh jimmy
i was balleting cars i went back to
parking cars
actually parking my agent's car and he
didn't tip very well
and he just hit me well swimming in
carmen now
pay him back for it so so phillip what
about you
well to our wine beer whiskey team i was
a liquor store clerk
uh with a couple other musicians that
also did the same thing
and then also i gave away free dance
lessons for a dance studio
i was a phone call like person like i'd
call you um hey would you like a free
dance lesson
oh my god how many times did you get on
that phone oh every nine out of ten
times hung up on
i was so hoping you were gonna say like
i worked at a dance studio and i gave
dance lessons like i was so hoping
that's what that
story was how it was gonna end so i'm a
little let down
whatever um but kim what about you
i was a waitress for a while when i
moved to nashville
um a little a little cafe and
right outside of nashville and i sold
sandwiches and sweet tea
oh that's i was a wager i feel like all
of us have waited tables or done some
kind of service industry job before
um everybody should wait tables at least
once everybody should wait
tables right this is this is what i say
kimberly yes this is what i say
because when you go to restaurants with
friends that and by the end of the meal
i'm questioning that
i'm like oh my gosh like you're so rude
like you have no idea what it's like to
like wait on
so many tables at once and everybody
wants their specific way they want
everything you know it's so hard
anyway um but it is a nice way to weed
out you know the weeds in your garden
though and you're like near not with you
anymore
[Music]
you